you are watching the press preview a
first look what's on the front pages as
they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and the
former government special adviser anita
blatting they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
the sun reports that lawyers for
virginia jeffrey who's suing prince
andrew over sexual assault allegations
have served him with legal documents he
strenuously denies any wrongdoing
that development is also the lead story
for the mirror
likewise it's the mail's top story
the telegraph hears that the government
is considering council tax increases to
pay for social care in addition to
controversial hikes to national
insurance
the guardian says gps are struggling to
guarantee safe levels of care due to a
shortage of staff
germany's frankfurter alga miner remarks
on the 20th anniversary of 9 11 tomorrow
with the headline when the war started
the daily express leads with the rollout
of fast-track driving tests for lorry
drivers in an attempt to prevent food
shortages at christmas
the times understands that elections
permitting boris johnson intends to be
prime minister for at least
a decade
the financial times reports that a u.s
judge has ruled against apple in a court
battle over fees at charges for apps
that take payments which don't go
directly through the apple store
and the star catches wind of a story
about the emissions of genetically
engineered
cows
and we're joined tonight by susie
boniface and anita watang welcome to you
both let's start with that story on the
front of the the guardian and the fact
that gp's saying that they're struggling
because of a lack of staff and also the
the argument about remote consultations
is brought into this piece susie
yeah there's lots of people who've spent
the last sort of year 18 months
criticizing gps and saying it's not fair
i demand the right to go and see him in
person about the thing that's not really
that bad and also those who quite
rightly complain that you know they
haven't been properly diagnosed because
they haven't been able to get in to see
their gp and here we can see some of the
the reason for that which is that you
know the paper there's reminding us in
2015 the government promised to hire 5
000 more gps over the next five years so
we should have them by now right um only
actually the numbers they haven't got
those five thousand and the numbers
dropped by four further thirteen hundred
so uh the gp numbers are five percent
below what they should be
uh and like anybody in any walk of life
if you're a tv presenter or journalist
or you're stacking yourself whatever it
might be if there are fewer of you in
the office doing the job then the the
job you do have to do you have to work
harder do it um faster do it for the
same money and
don't do quite such a good job as you
would do otherwise which is why cutbacks
everywhere are usually a terrible idea
and that's what's happened here gps are
saying here that they just don't feel
now as safe as they should be and
if the gps don't feel safe then the
patients aren't going to feel any safer
either are they
the articles pointing to uh professor
martin marshall chair of the royal
college of gps and he's defending the
growing use of remote consultations
during the pandemic anita but we have
heard previously i think in the last
couple of days from coroners saying that
the deaths that they've seen are
potentially due to the fact that
patients couldn't see their gps for
face-to-face consultations in
time yes it feels as though some of the
quality and some of the nuance that
perhaps you might be able to get via a
face-to-face consultation is being lost
by a remote consultations look the
entire system has to have a degree of
flexibility because obviously because of
i think the thing that susie's probably
missed from that account is the growing
demand that's being placed on gps both
because of general population growth
backlog and all the other things that
are not really affected and of the
result of any government policy
decisions and so you need to get a
balance between that increased
efficiency that you might see
remote consultations and obviously the
need for face-to-face contact to
continue
let's move on to the express um and this
is a story that we've all been uh too
aware of uh the fact that it's being
predicted that things are running out
the shelves are empty um what is the the
remedy to preventing our shells being
empty uh just before christmas
susie
well according to the daily express
which campaign loudly for brexit this uh
hasn't had the word brexit anywhere on
the front page
uh it's blamed the shortage of drivers
on the government not doing enough and
what course the government hasn't done
uh is allow visas for foreign drivers to
come in and try and fill this shortage
that we've got at the very least in the
short term but more interestingly is if
you kind of look elsewhere and the
express isn't really mentioning it here
is that the chairman of the food and
drink federation said today this isn't
just a driver shortage issue this is a
problem of how our supply chains have
been built over time you know the
british economy was was
built in such a way that was called just
in time alright so whenever you went to
the shop you had anything you wanted in
that shop pretty much and they were
always delivered at the last minute and
being in eu enabled that to happen
because of the changes that have been
brought about the ceo of the food and
drink federation
right says that that's never going to
happen again now he does say it's a
first world problem for example last
week uh i think people in the east of
england weren't able to have deliveries
of bottled water which of course you can
get out of the tap it's not the end of
the world not to have deliveries a
bottled water but it does mean that when
you go to the shops he says forever from
now on not just at christmas not just
because of a bit of a brexit hiccup but
forever
our supply chains have been radically
and fundamentally altered in the long
term and there will be shortages on
shelves he says long past christmas and
even if the government does actually
provide some uh
some new licenses and testing here for
hgv drivers which is what the store is
talking about of course that puts up
prices for what you get on the shelves
at christmas if they can get it there at
all so then you're looking at inflation
you're looking at your money not going
as far as it should do and a lot of
people's christmas is going to be
significantly tighter and worse than it
could otherwise be anita stories like
this are going to lead to people panic
buying aren't they i mean we've seen it
before in the early stages of the the
pandemic with uh people stocking up
unnecessarily on on toilet rolls but
stories like this now
really could lead to to a panic
i'm not quite so doom and gloom about
this obviously the you know when it
comes to christmas lots of people do
tend to buy a little more and that puts
pressure on the chain in general look i
i think susie makes an interesting point
about the ways in which the way that we
shop has been engineered over the past
sort of two decades to ensure that we
keep prices low and margins incredibly
low and that has made it very
challenging for the model around
delivery of food in particular to change
um but i think part of the story that's
missing probably from that account is
really about the pay and conditions of
some of these drivers that deliver um
the products that we rely on on in that
just just-in-time way and i think what
we're really seeing here is some of that
coming to a head where the paying
conditions as well as a pandemic have
forced people into different professions
and there needs to be a kind of
consideration of what we can do in terms
of that pay and conditions the
fundamental issue to address um what has
led to a fall in supply of these drivers
and i think that fundamentally you know
we can do what we can do around ensuring
that people can have those tests but
really it's a pain the conditions are
going to make a difference to getting
those lorry driver numbers up to ensure
that we have something that looks much
more like what we're used to outside of
covert time susie to the times and uh
contrary to what dominic cummings would
have us believe it seems the prime
minister
would like to stay in the job a little
bit longer dominic cummings was
suggesting uh prior to to this that uh
he was actually sick of it and couldn't
take the the difficulty of the task but
what do we believe
well
um it's not just dominic cummings
there's been a number of sort of uh
leaks and so on from within daniel
street that have sort of said boris
johnson liking the job of being prime
ministers not being as much fun as he
thought it was going to be and likening
it to sort of strapping a jumbo jet onto
your back every morning and trying to
drag it along the runway um and i think
anybody who actually looks at the man
can see that he he doesn't look exactly
in fine fettle and doesn't like he's
enjoying it that much and also isn't
having much fun because all the things
he would want to do that would be fun
mad bridges and air reports and stuff
like this just aren't happening and he's
having lots of arguments and problems
however
what this story is about is saying boris
johnson saying i want to be in power for
11 years and there's a minister who has
briefed uh the times about this and he
wants to go on longer than thatcher
which some people are going to be crying
blood over that idea but
really interestingly here um let's do
everything with boris johnson you don't
listen to what the man says but you have
to look at what the man actually does
because they're usually completely
opposite things and right next to this
story on the front page there's one
about how major planning reforms have
had to be utterly scrapped because he is
going to lose seats right across the
south if he carries on with the idea of
um allowing some of these planning
reforms which would stop people
objecting to new housing and so on and
so forth so that's big idea number one
straight out the window and if you turn
the page over this page four there's a
huge piece about how boris johnson's
gonna have to decide whether or not to
scrap the eastern leg of hs2 it was
already brief that that was going to be
scrapped he's going to make a decision
shortly but again it's another big
project another big scheme that he's not
able to push through doesn't have the
cash he doesn't have the political
capital look at the telegraph front page
and this story will come as depressing
reading to many families already reeling
from the national insurance increase
that they have to face but now according
to the telegraph uh council tax bills
will also uh increase uh come april
anita
yes i think this one is really i mean
it's a pretty speculative story but
absolutely given we know the way that
the council tax is structured um there's
likely to be some leeway for councils um
to raise the precept that people pay on
their council tax which could go towards
supporting again social care um and i
think that actually this is quite an
important story in the context of the
conservative party seeing some possible
movements in the polls as a result of it
in my view really gripping something
there's been a challenge for almost a
decade to ensure there's a better flow
of funding and a broader base of funding
for social care and i kind of think that
this is sort of what we want to see
which is investment both from
local councils but also from additional
taxation susie uh government spokesmans
are quoted as saying that we will ensure
every council has the resources they
need to deliver these reforms with extra
money invested next year and 5.4 billion
by 2024-25
yeah it's not a particularly speculative
story because it mentions here there is
a clause within the announcement last
week that says the cat the cap on local
authorities raising their council tax
precept for social care may well be
lifted in the budget next month
so it does look as though the tax rise
we were sold as being the once in a
lifetime sort of settlement for social
care
is not going to be anything of the sort
and we need to remember of course local
authorities bore the brunt of about 50
of the austerity cuts and they're the
ones who provide social care unless the
government hands money out it's not
gonna work we are running out of time
very quickly anita tell us about the
cows in the star
um
i think that what we're seeing is um a
possible new innovation it's incredibly
exciting what we might see
is cows being bred um to sort of stop
the ways in which their methane
emissions massively affect climate
change so we might be saving the world
one cow at a time very well done anita
you didn't say the dreaded word that i
think the star have used thank you both